[Música]
si buscas resultados distintos no hagas
siempre lo mismo
bueno pues nada
por favor
esto no es fácil
empezamos
hola buenas tardes a todos
mi nombre es beyoncé
y vengo aquí a presentar un fragmento
muy breve del baile que me hizo
mundialmente famosa
de la canción extraída de la canción
single ladies que seguramente conoceréis
lo voy a ejecutar además sin ningún tipo
de ayuda
sin ningún tipo de música sin
acompañamiento totalmente a capella
yo creo que os va a gustar hace así
12 12 31 21 23
[Aplausos]
bueno la verdad la verdad vale yo no
quiero aquí engaña a nadie los de la
primera fila se habrá dado cuenta la
segunda también con esa cara ni de coña
yo yo no soy yo no soy mujer
visto lo visto podría haberlo sido pero
no soy mujer no se ama no canto bien yo
no canto bien yo yo no bailo bien en
definitiva yo quiero deciros aquí
sincerarme yo lo siento mucho yo no soy
beyoncé no no no no no lo soy no
tuviéramos lo mucho es ay toni segarra y
beyoncé en el cartel del tlc y siempre
de barcelona- cartelazo pues no ni soy
ni soy víctor amela ni soy víctor
parrado unitaria ni ninguno de mis
maravillosos compañeros que me acompañan
ellos solamente con su presencia
solamente con su voz solamente con su
imagen son capaces de lanzar un mensaje
súper súper motivador súper creativo
súper original a todos vosotros yo en
cambio tengo que hacer algo de
espectáculo para que alguien hoy aquí
después de todas estas conferencias se
haga el más mínimo caso
yo me llamo sergio ayala
y
y vengo a presentar mi manifiesto en
favor de los hombres medios los hombres
medios son las personas que también
desde la normalidad tenemos la capacidad
y el derecho de perseguir nuestros
nuestros sueños la capacidad y el
derecho de buscar nuestros objetivos la
capacidad de derecha en definitiva de
alcanzar el éxito y eso lo voy a hacer
hablando muy brevemente es de tres
pilares tres pilares básicos que a mí me
cambió la vida tres pilares básicos que
hacen que yo y esté aquí en este cd es
mirar el primero de ellos sin duda
ninguna es la diferenciación la
diferencia es la capacidad que tenemos
todas las personas de dar un mapa a lo
que hacemos un bat es un valor añadido
personal a nuestro producto a nuestro
servicio incluso o incluso a nuestra
marca personal la diferenciación de
hecho es lo que hace que yo estoy aquí
hoy miraras trate de c's han llamado los
mejores
han llamado a los mejores y a mí
a mí no me han llamado por ser el mejor
y eso lo tengo claro sería un iluso yo
sé que no soy el mejor porque no ha sido
el mejor nunca en nada en mi vida ni
nada de lo que he hecho a mi mañana o
simplemente porque soy diferente porque
puedo ser capaz de dar un valor añadido
diferencial a lo que hago pero para mí
eso es suficiente porque gracias a eso
yo hoy puedo estar aquí como dándome con
los mejores para mí es brutal pero ojo
porque esa diferenciación no puede ser
gratuita esa diferenciación además es
peligrosa porque no todo lo diferente es
bueno el brócoli por ejemplo por ejemplo
no no todo lo diferente es bueno la
diferenciación tiene que ser una
diferenciación positiva tienes una
diferencia en inteligente tiene ser
nacional tiene que ser coherente de
forma que el mensaje que yo mando y como
lo transmito forma parte de un todo
congruente de un todo congruente y para
eso además me puedo apoyar en lo que en
psicología cognitiva hablan de la teoría
de la primacía y la regencia que es que
empieza bien y acaba mejor porque nos
acordamos fundamentalmente de lo primero
y de lo útil como que vivimos empieza
creando expectativas y acabarás creando
interés
este es el primero de los pilares el
segundo de los pilares
de alcanzar el éxito de la gente normal
sin duda ninguna es la valentía la
valentía ya tenemos claro cuáles son
nuestros elementos diferenciadores
ostras pero hay que ponernos en práctica
ya tenemos claro en nuestro laboratorio
de ideas que lo que queremos hacer para
diferenciarnos de la gente del resto de
nuestro producto de nuestro servicio
pero ahora tenemos que poner en valor
tengo que poner el mercado hay que
sacarlo es decir tenemos que empezar a
dejar de soñar y empezar a soñar y hacer
tenemos que empezar a dejar de
ilusionarnos y empezar a ilusionarnos y
accionar nos esta es la clave y a la
gente normal sólo nos queda un recurso
para la valentía que es ese recurso esa
frase ese mantra que nos tenemos que
repetir constantemente constantemente si
eres un crack o tiene mucha pasta esto
no va con vosotros el problema soy yo el
problema somos la gente normal y está
que tenemos que repetir nos
constantemente una frase una frase una y
otra vez una y otra vez y nada otra vez
que es la frase que ha hecho que las
civilizaciones se hayan avanzado desde
la prehistoria hasta la edad moderna que
es la frase que ha hecho que todos los
que estáis aquí hoy sentados en algún
momento dados
os habéis empoderado de vuestra valentía
y la frase es esta ya lo tengo todo
claro lo racionalizado todo lo analizado
todo ya sé hacia dónde tengo que tirar
ahora que lo hago o no lo hago
lo hago ya tomar por culo
claro claro no es esto la valentía no
eso es empoderarse de la valentía y me
queda un tercer pilar que es la
resiliencia que es la capacidad que
tenemos todas las personas de
levantarnos una vez más solamente una
vez más y es lo que nos da la esencia
del ser humano es verdad que los
animales también lo hacen también lo
intentan una y otra vez una y otra vez
también lo hacen pero lo hacen por
instinto
nosotros tenemos una carga negativa
emocional tan dura cada vez que
fracasamos que para nosotros
complicadísimo hacerlo y por eso estamos
salvados porque tenemos una fórmula que
la fórmula del éxito la fórmula que nos
salva de todas estas caídas que tenemos
y que nos hace que nos podamos levantar
una vez más mirar la fórmula dice es
igual a x + 1 es una fórmula clave es
igual a x + 1 donde la x es las veces
que nos caemos y el + 1 es la vez que
nos tenemos que levantar que siempre
tiene que sumar 1
solo una vez más voy a poner ejemplo
además es que esta fórmula la tenemos
metida en nuestro adn si nosotros
hiciéramos una disección horizontal de
nuestra cadena de adn en el centro en el
núcleo está esta fórmula mira voy a
poner ejemplo clarísimo mirar el otro
día estaba buscando cosas por internet y
un foro de padres yo tengo dos hijos
además bueno no puedo ver padres una
madre pregunta en el foro mi hija tiene
13 meses y todavía no puede caminar
cuento lo normal que una niña se caiga
al día tu fíjate la madre la pregunta de
trastornada que estamos en o está
preocupada porque su hija la torpe
bueno pues hay un tío que se le va la
pinza más a un calculado
yo lo calculado
dice lo normal es que un niño de 13
meses se caiga 5 veces a la hora lo
privado por amor de dios esto que no ha
calculado bueno vale y entonces yo
tienes cálculos también también tengo
dos hijos y 9 3 y 15 12
nos llevó dos vale y yo calculado cuánto
tardó mi hijo en caminar y resulta que
mi hijo que él tardó en caminar 90 días
entre los 12 y los 15 meses unos 90 días
más o menos 90 días desde el primer día
que intentaba ponerse de pie subiéndose
a la mesa hasta que empezó a correr por
delante del brócoli de mi mujer
vale no sea porque también corría
delante el bribón adegua 90 días y
también calculé cuánto tiempo permanece
un niño activo al día en actitud de
caminar y calculé gran 10 horas activos
al día porque las otras 10 horas estaba
durmiendo dos horas comiendo y dos horas
con una pataleta en cerrar una
habitación vale imaginaros 10 horas
activo al día x 5 pinos a la hora x 90
días que son tres meses da un total de
4500 pinos
4500 hostias no son pocas no no son
pocas no son pocas cuadrilla de ostia
nos convoca y porque camina un niño un
niño camina por dos cosas por dos
motivos solamente por dos motivos el
primero porque se ha levantado 4500
vosotros camináis habéis caminado porque
os habéis levantado 4500 una vez y el
segundo de los motivos es muy fácil
porque nadie le había dicho a ese niño
que lo que iba a hacer era imposible
nadie se lo había dicho a ningún padre
que le diga oye cariño llevas tres
hostias déjalo dejarlo porque no no vas
a caminar
a la mente a la vez oye cariño llevas 20
hostias dedícate a reptar
por el suelo porque tú no vas a caminar
en tu vida no sólo decimos ya nos
encargamos ya nos encargamos de hablarle
de imposibilidades un poquito más tarde
le decía lo hacemos luego las hadas no
lo hacemos no lo hacemos mira yo doy
muchas charlas en foros de
emprendedurismo y me se acerca una
persona de hoy en sergio es que yo he
montado otras empresas tío y la chapa o
las tres pero tú cuántos años tiene 95
tío hasta 4.500 empresas estás preparado
genéticamente preparado tío crear la
empresa pégate la castaña aprende de tus
errores levántate el link startup es
esto fracasa rápido pero fracasa y
barato si puede ser barato
en foros de empleabilidad hoy es
escogido a 3 entrevista de trabajo
esther marino me cogen y hasta 4.500
centros y listas estás preparado colinas
los que sois feos
no digáis el sergio que en olivos ya dio
ver o catas en discoteca o cuántos hay
pero si al final el éxito es cuestión de
estadística 123 empieza hasta 4500
tienes de cancha y no estamos preparados
estamos preparados que que es el éxito
el éxito lo decía paula antes el éxito
es ponerte unas zapatillas unas
zapatillas de correr y salir a correr el
éxito es caerte
levantarte una y otra vez una y otra vez
una y otra vez mirar dentro de unos
meses yo seguramente estaré en el
maravilloso color de mi mujer en los
líquidos en requena y seguramente estaré
vendimiando con mi cuñado pero antonio
es una de delinear yo ya lo
digo o sea
si podéis hacer otras cosas
y entonces está bien y me han de vender
un amigo mío media oye sergio y youtube
eso del tex de barcelona como te salió
te pusiste nervioso pues mira estaba
nerviosísimo estaba súper atacado lo
pasé fatal porque porque había mucha
gente tiempo que además me tenía que
hacer la conferencia mientras me vestía
y yo me quedo en blanco tíos y un
puñetero desastre tibán imaginen me
llena la boca de saliva y balbuceó el
ermis asqueroso pero te salió bien o no
sitio me salió bien
no no me salió muy bien qué
suerte no qué bien no tío no no me jodas
suerte no
te voy a decir por qué me salió bien
me salió bien porque esa conferencia
ensayo 4500
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]